hey everybody hey everybody welcome to
this week in startups it's our 900th
episode can you believe it ten years ago
we started a little podcast with the
zoom recorder on a desk and here we are
nine hundred episodes later and we have
an amazing guest today Justin Kahn is a
serial founder he has been through Y
Combinator four times he's had a ton of
failures as he is frequently reminding
everybody but he built a unicorn
twitch TV which twitch was bought by
Amazon and has become a huge huge
success and now he started another
company atrium
he was also had his fingerprints on
crews another billion dollar exit angel
investor my brother and Kyle my twitch
co-founder started it yeah well welcome
to the program finally I'm trying to
have you on here for ten years I've been
trying to get on for tonight and now I
know I got tired of waiting outside the
lobby exactly exactly
well it's good to see you for people who
don't know Justin TV started when 2008
was 2007 we launched in 2000 we actually
started the company at the end of 2006
as much as you can call it a company and
we launched it in March of 2007 March
19th I think and then lasted for about
six months of us trying to make our own
web reality show yeah and that was that
was the start and most people nowadays
don't even remember they're like what
was just the TV they don't know and it
then became a platform at some point
where anybody could use it but here you
are I think this is the first episode or
what is it what is the city over
watching of you with with Justin TV you
can watch broadcast and share live video
and chat with other viewers check out
the directory for what's live right now
the schedule for what's coming on soon
and the coupon for best video highlights
I think that's like a promo video from
the early days that I just recorded that
would autoplay or something when you
went to the site this is like your
friend Tom at the exact Tom and myspace
I met myspace Tom at myspace welcome
this is hilarious yes we stored it off
as our own us trying to make our own
reality show and this is like before
social media before yeah keeping up with
the kardashians we were like it would be
cool if you just create a show about
some bunch of random dudes lives yeah
unfortunately was not interesting in any
way right and
mostly it was us playing around our
computers programming and people would
log on and say you know what are you
doing get get up get the [ __ ] off your
computer go write in us and so we didn't
know how to do that because we were
media people right we were programmers
engineers yeah so what we did was we
build his platform that was kind of like
YouTube for live video and we launched
it in October of 2007 we launched it to
the world and anyone could start
streaming now what phones did it support
in the beginning because back then we
didn't have LTE or 4G it was 3G networks
yeah there were no phones so everyone
was desktop streaming from their
desktops or laptops yeah right and there
was a lot of people trying to create
mobile streams but they what was that
Nokia one there was a Nokia phone like
the n95 or 795 yeah yeah didn't really
work very good it didn't work at all it
was sort of like sending like a picture
every three seconds
yes jump yeah and yeah if we have some
clips I think of that which are it was
like we people would set up these
streams off laptop computers with a 3G
card like yeah video card yeah you slide
it in yeah you plug it in the USB and
then would connect your you to the the
internet and it would just be like 100
kilobits per second or so so you could
get this like jittery stream
I remember at some point Robert Scoble
and Leo Laporte running around maybe
South by Southwest with like mobile gear
yes and they had laptops in their
backpack that was those the whole
premise or thing at the webcam like on a
stick like literally a logitech webcam
on a stack and they would bind two of
these like a video cards together
together reflects a video off a multi
plateau it's hilarious and now people
are just like take out their phone and
if you think about stories I think
actually you were kind of the Godfather
of the stories moment because it was the
same idea yep except with stories like
the thing is most people running around
with a live camera are not interesting
95 to 99 percent of the time
correct every hour you shoot like two
minutes are interesting and the genius
behind stories on what Evan created with
snapchat was he was like just
take the moments the highlights of your
day and then you can watch the
highlights of your day and maybe that's
interesting instead of the other five
hours that you spent you know messing
around on your computer yeah cuz it's
edited down so it's literally like the
cream of that so we're kind of right
there except we completely missed the
boat but there was some really prescient
moment where you realize gamers were
genre unto themselves cuz I remember
back in 2007-2008 I was doing mahalo and
we started putting video video game
videos right on the YouTube about
YouTube and they went bonkers like
millions of views but when did you
realize video games were what streaming
was about yeah so how did that happen
well so we launched this site in 2006 or
2007 and that anyone could stream
anything and people stream there was a
lot of like people trying to make talk
shows and a lot of social kind of
broadcasting like someone would just be
hanging out and then there was this
nascent category which I kind of grew
that mostly focused on trying to get
celebrities and things like you know
more famous people to create content the
problem was they didn't really want to
do it on an ongoing basis right and so a
couple years later this was maybe in
2010 we'd grown to a fairly big website
it was about like the top 300 on Alexa
or something like that she got over 10
million people a month basically yeah
something something around that but the
problem was it stopped growing and we're
like we had no idea how to grow
justin.tv this web platform for frame
wanted to stream so what we decided to
do was go back to the drawing board and
basically sit in a room and try to
brainstorm ideas and my co-founder
Emmett came with his idea and his idea
was was let's focus on the gaming
content on our site which was only three
percent of the content at the time and
so gaming was only I think a couple
hundred thousand uniques a month on our
site but his argument was this is the
only type of content that I actually
want to watch right so our craft too had
just come out
Oh so that was driving a lot of interest
absolutely and that was driving a lot of
YouTube videos and you want to watch
live streams and mostly they were on
other people's sites they were on
Ustream or livestream or but he thought
we could focus on this and build a
community around the team people had a
desert Gresh
exactly you know micro and you know God
that game was so amazed I love those
real-time strategy games so glad I
stopped playing them because I was so
into Age of Empires at one point you
know that I would sit there like smoking
a cigar at 4:00 in the morning and I'd
be like I've been playing this game
since 10:00 p.m. everybody's asleep and
I'm sitting like in my study
yeah as a 35 year old grown up playing
Age of Empires with like chess when you
hit like that eight hours of play and
you're like this I've worked a full day
at this video game right that's when you
know you have a problem and you're like
and I have to be in an office to be CEO
in four hours so what am I doing with my
life but how did you make the decision
to spin it out because that yeah was I
remember watching that I was like oh
that's smart two swings at the bad well
how do you go to investors and convince
them to do that because didn't the third
started Socialcam he took one startup
yep turn and you made it 2/3 cap tables
three swings that bad well technically
it was two but what happened was so we
had this company we had raised about
seven million dollars in metro financing
I could amount back then a good about
good amount back then yeah now the
rounds are you know hundreds of millions
of whatever but back then you know seven
seven million was good there were all
these other I don't know if you remember
back in 2009 there were all these other
video star ups like vo and rapture and
they basically all went out of business
because you know the market crashed it
can raise any more money the ad revenue
wasn't there yet the video address it
wasn't there yet YouTube had just turned
on monetization around that time exactly
and so what we did decided to do was we
basically went into cockroach mode and
we just survived as we were like we're
never gonna raise any more money so we
just survived and trying to monetize any
way possible so we'd add like there was
a fence of amount of advertising on the
site I know etc cutting cost like we
would racked our own servers we like
built our own infrastructure we were
like in the the data centers like trying
to basically to optimize costs because
we were too cheap to use like AWS right
so we spent a couple years in this
survival mode and then finally we were
like we need to start making it grow
again and so and this is what your six
of the business this is 2011 so that is
five years and and the company was about
twenty-five people
so we decided to work on like we went to
that ideation meeting and we were like
what are we gonna build that's gonna
build you know be bigger than this and
so we had these two ideas one was ahem
its idea which was twitch and the other
was an idea that actually Michael my
other co-founders now the CEO of Y
Combinator came up with which was social
camel it's kind of a mobile video app
Michael Seibel was your co-founder at
Justin yeah so Michael Emmett and Kyle
was causing co-founder of cruising
fantasy over former CEO and co-founder
of cruise we're all white for cocoa so I
lucked out I got three town there were
three talented co-founders and and I got
slid in them in the back door but it was
your idea the idea you come up with the
idea you can yeah then you can you can
use a lot easier exactly I got a reverse
it's kind of your C founder Authority
yeah so how do you so we so what
happened with the cafe and stuff is we
came up with this idea for twitch and
then we came up with this idea for a
social cam that was Michaels idea
because we had seen Instagram here's
like someone should make the Instagram a
video and we couldn't decide the four of
us like Michael was technically the CEO
of the company at that time but we
basically ran everything through these
like horrible consensus driven thing
yeah exactly yeah a lot of first-time
founders will recognize this it's like
when you're you are sitting around the
table you you're best friends but you
can't decide who should be in charge so
you just like argue about everything
that's exactly what we were doing which
is a horrible way to decide anything and
so Michael and I liked social well I
liked both ideas and then but Emma and
Kyle didn't think that sorry
well whatever the configuration doesn't
matter but basically we couldn't decide
so what we decided to do was we incubate
both ideas internally under the theory
that if they were both successful that
was like a champagne problem to have
right the problem is as you know is when
you work on multiple things in one
company it is not as do or die anymore i
people always think oh i can go to the
next thing or whatever so eventually
what happened was we decided we needed
to choose and we need to spin one of the
companies out and so Socialcam twitch
was basically the same infrastructure
was almost like a reskin justin.tv at
first right so that it made sense to
keep that as the same company and we
took Socialcam and we spun it out into a
new company some of the engineers
becoming the new co found
and Michael went and became the CEO of
that company all right when we get back
I want to talk about how this five year
old meandering startup that probably a
lot of investor candidly probably wrote
off at that point yeah fair yeah I think
we were universally [ __ ] upon right okay
I was trying to be a little bit more
magnanimous about it maybe they had
written it off yeah they ship on it when
we get back how does this five-year-old
[ __ ] on startup become a billion dollar
unicorn purchase by Jeff Bezos when we
get back on the speedsters
[Music]